last week after I told you that the CIA
uh issued a statement saying we believe
that not only was Russia involved in
hacking in order to help Donald Trump
win the 2016 presidential election but
we have now also learned that Vladimir
Putin the former KGB agent and current
Russian president was also involved
specifically in terms of how the
information would be used etcetera
etcetera the reactions from the trumpets
were varied but also not so varied but
one of the main retorts was David listen
the CIA might think that but the FBI
doesn't think that the FBI disagrees
James Comey doesn't agree and I trust
the FBI more than the CIA the CIA is
political David but the FBI is not well
yeah right we learned that that's
obviously not the case after James
commis ill-advised press conferences
letters etcetera relating to the Hillary
Clinton email situation but needless to
say we have now learned that the FBI
agrees with the assessment of the fs CIA
that Russian hacking that we now know
Vladimir Putin was also involved in did
have the goal of helping Donald Trump
become president of the United States
officials over the weekend discussed
that FBI director James Comey Director
of National Intelligence James clapper
they are in agreement with that CIA
assessment that Russia intervened to
help Donald Trump win the White House
the positions of come--and clapper were
revealed in a message that CIA director
John Brennan sent to the agency's work
force on Friday saying quote earlier
this week I met separately with FBI
director James Comey and Director of
National Intelligence Jim clapper and
there is strong consensus among us on
the scope nature and intent of Russian
interference in our presidential
election so this puts to rest a few
talking points including that the FBI
and CIA are not on the same page on the
issue now the FBI that has been
praised by Republicans as being the good
intelligence agency because they told
the truth about Hillary Clinton's emails
is the same FBI Pat that says yes Russia
hacked us to help Donald Trump yeah
there's no reason to believe that these
three intelligence agencies are all in a
conspiracy to attack Trump but it's
interesting because Donald Trump is
poised to run these uh these three
intelligence agencies and only a month
and now he's criticizing all three of
them yeah this is as I mentioned last
week one of the hallmarks of the sort of
pseudo populists authoritarian strongman
is to express skepticism about all
aspects of government including elements
of the government that you oversee like
intelligence agencies but but but
congressional Republicans would never
play politics with national security
information because that's what they
accused Hillary Clinton of doing with
Benghazi ride the reality is there was
always this consensus the FBI was
quieter about it and the reason that
this is a big deal is that the FBI
hesitating to be this clear was used by
the right-wingers to disqualify and
ignore the findings of numerous
intelligence agencies including the FPV
CIA we have the FBI and CIA now that
this is clear saying that a foreign
government has intervened to help
someone win the American presidency
meanwhile things continue business as
usual Trump campaign doing anything it
can think of to pretend that the story
is bogus but it grows and it grows and
it grows and this should be headline
news on every news outlet CIA and FBI
agree Russia hacked us to help Trump win
and it worked people should be outraged
that Russia did this and yet everyone
seems oddly accepting of Russian
interference as if it's kind of not a
big deal yeah you should be outraged all
by this regardless of which candidate
you supported this is the legitimacy of
our elections that stay here and
trumpets see conspiracies everywhere
except for where they're actually seems
to be one and there's consensus that
there was one according to intelligence
agencies millions of undocumented
immigrants voted for Hillary Clinton and
Trump
otherwise won the popular vote there's a
major cover-up of Hillary's health
Obama's fake birth certificate pizzagate
on and on and on all sorts of
conspiracies except for the one that
both the FBI and the CIA now agree on